no you have your podcast american
glutton podcast which in california you
think they they should have an american
gluten podcast
they probably do but by the way what so
what what do you do on the podcast on
american glutton podcast
it's really you know um
uh another guy who who you will remember
from back then kevin connolly
um we were going to japan
like maybe 10 years ago and we got on
the plane
and he was like what the hell are you
gonna do for 14 hours
and i said i'm going to listen to this
dan carlin podcast about you know the
history of the mongols or something
whatever it was some series where you
got 14 hours of content from dan carlin
who's like
the god of history um
and he was like what's a podcast so i
showed him he downloaded the app
he didn't sleep on the plane he listened
to the whole thing straight through
we landed in japan and then the entire
trip we were on
he was consumed with podcasts and just
like
couldn't believe that this existed and
that people were just
talking and having conversations and and
so
he became kind of obsessed and he
created this podcasting
studio um called the action park media
and he before before they launched he
was kind of
saying to me you have to come do a
podcast
uh he wanted me to do one about politics
because i'm very much a contrarian and i
kind of
uh overtly despise all politicians so no
matter what anybody's happy about
in politics i'll just try to rain
down on it
and i said to him there is no way
that i'm gonna do that it's such like a
not a
thing to do because i have that
conversation with you
but it's not a public conversation it's
not anything i'm interested in
talking about publicly um and he was
like
come on push like one day i woke up
when he was asking me and i was like oh
i can fully talk about health and
fitness because i've done that
and it a lot of the way i look at it is
very analogous to how i look at politics
or philosophy or any of these things
um so we talk about health and fitness
but if anybody wants to
like listen to it
and you can very easily figure out that
i am just not interested in the
political system that we have
right and also there's enough shows
about politics
and when you talk about health and life
and in my show we talk about anxiety and
facing adversity and this and that and
uh it's something that
some people can relate to and politics
is just something that everybody just
starts arguing about and everybody has
their own opinion and
health is something you know health is
something that's universal and that i
think anybody could listen to so it just
it makes more sense
i think you'd be you're probably happier
than you would be if you're doing a
political
uh podcast yeah i mean um i would
yes for sure because i i i you know
it's i don't think it's fun i think it's
a fun conversation to have with somebody
who
you know at the end of it even if they
get mad at you
they're not gonna like write you off as
a bad person right right
you can't i can't do that um with the
with pup
i don't think anybody can like i think
it's it's a divide that's set that
uh once you're on whatever line you're
on
and i don't even believe in in the left
right line so much
but just like whatever team you somebody
associates you with
some team and if that's not your team
you you know so it's like it's just
not a
a and and and to your point like it's
the most over discussed thing
in america